et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
geoffroy didier bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous est député
européen directeur de la communication
de valérie pécresse on est ensemble
pendant vingt minutes comme une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern et bonjour stéphane
bonjour jour qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france on va
bien sûr parler du passé maxine aller et
de cette visite des manuels mâcon de la
présidentielle mais d'abord un mot
puisqu'on a appris cette nuit le décès
du président du parlement européen le
social démocrate italien david ça ce
livre est député européen s'offre à nous
et quelle est votre réaction je suis
très triste très triste parce que david
sassoli était malade depuis de nombreux
mois maintenant et qu'il avait dû donc
quitté l'hémicycle du parlement européen
de strasbourg depuis trop longtemps
triste évidemment pour sa famille pour
tous ses collaborateurs auxquels je
pense aujourd'hui pour tous ses proches
est triste pour l'institution européenne
dont il était le garant le messager et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un
vrai message puisque c'est la présidence
française de l'union européenne à porter
c'est à dire que nous avons nous devons
avoir une france forte mais aussi une
europe puissante puissante à l'égard de
la concurrence sans pitié que nous
livrent les états unis la chine et
d'autres pays et puissante politiquement
parce que nous sommes dans un monde en
constante danger et qu'il est temps que
l'europe s'affirme pas une robe les à
calais thallion sans toi y en aura pour
nom pas suffisamment pas suffisamment
elle a été trop naïve dans la
mondialisation et il faut par exemple
imposer la réciprocité dans les échanges
commerciaux entre l'union européenne
d'une part et les autres continents
d'autre part et ça n'a pas été
suffisamment fait par le passé donc un
véritable hommage ce matin david sassoli
mais aussi un message un message pour
l'ensemble de l'union européenne qui
doit être beaucoup plus puissante face
aux autres continents et pour emmanuel
macron juste qu'il s'exprimera qui fera
un grand discours la semaine prochaine
justement devant le parlement parce que
vous donc j'aurais préféré que la
présidence française de l'union
européenne soit reportée parce que nous
savons nous sommes dans une échéance
présidentielle
nous savons emmanuel macron va être
comme c'est d'ailleurs à son habitude
condamné au à dire des mots et à ne pas
pouvoir réaliser des actes c'est ma
langue française pour rien selon en tout
cas j'aurais préféré que qu'elle soit
reportée je ne souhaite pas que ce soit
une présidence française pour rien je
souhaite que des sujets comme par
exemple celui que je porte parlement
européen c'est à dire que le digital
services act pardon de cette non en
anglais mais puisque c'est l'expression
consacrée de ce projet de règlement
européen et qui visent à réguler les
gars femmes puissent être portées dans
le cas de la présidence française de
l'union européenne mais à vrai dire
j'aurais préféré que cette présidence ne
soit pas uniquement un moment de débat
mais un moment de réformes d'actes et le
fait que nous soyons en pleine échéances
présidentielles avec une élection
structurantes ne permettra pas d'agir de
réformer d'avancé comme nous aurions
voulu que ce soit le cas juste une
précision ça aurait été vraiment
possible la reporter s'il avait fallu
reporter la présidence européenne par la
france il aura fallu attendre combien de
temps on aurait pu
reporter de six mois six mois simplement
ce tweet on aurait pu et c'est ce qui
s'est passé déjà en allemagne il ya
plusieurs années ou un moment où il y
avait des élections en allemagne mais
l'allemagne avait fait le choix de
reporter l'élection à la présidence
française voilà on va parler du passé
actional puisque le texte arrive au
sénat aujourd'hui mais jean castex a
annoncé hier une nouvelle modification
du protocole dans les écoles nouvelle
puisque c'est la troisième en une
semaine les élèves candidats que plus de
tests pcr uniquement de les autotests ça
c'est pour simplifier le protocole pour
éviter les files d'attentes des enfants
devant les pharmacies devant les labos
est-ce que vous approuvez ce protocole
vous trouvez ça simple ou mais ce qui
est marrant c'est que dans votre
question vous avez dit c'est la
troisième fois qu'on change dans une
semaine et l'objectif est de simplifier
on n'y comprend plus rien lorsque
valérie pécresse avait demandé un report
de la rentrée scolaire
je crois qu'elle avait plus que raison
parce qu'il fallait que le gouvernement
puisse donner aux parents d'élèves aux
enseignants un protocole claire
permettant à chacun d'anticiper c'est
tout le contraire ce qui s'est passé
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
une confusion immense au sein des
établissements scolaires avec une
incapacité pour les parents d'élèves à
anticiper et un protocole qui changent
quasiment tous les jours et
souvenez-vous que le premier protocole
pour la rentrée n'a été rendue publique
que la veille de la rentrée scolaire
donc les sens les parents d'élèves dans
le flou absolu et prenons le risque
d'une désorganisation qui d'ailleurs
désormais manifeste à l'école où nous
savions très bien que vu la contagion
actuelle du virus lakovic 19 que
beaucoup d'enseignants ne pourrait pas
prodigué leurs enseignements donc c'est
tout le contraire qui aurait dû être
fait c'est à dire qu'on aurait dû
reporter la rentrée scolaire
anticiper tout pour qu'il n'y ait aucune
confusion en tout cas le moins possible
face à la situation de la co vide et
j'estime vraiment que là dessus le
gouvernement a lamentablement échoué
parce que c'est bon plusieurs syndicats
de professeurs des écoles qui appellent
à la grève ce jeudi elle sera
manifestement très suivie vous les
comprenez est ce que vous les soutenez
moi je ne suis pas un gréviste dans
l'âme je préfère toujours être aux
avant-postes agir et ne rien lâcher mais
je comprends le désarroi je comprends la
confusion immense qui existe je
comprends la capacité l'incapacité à
anticiper et je comprends il
chacun son rôle un acteur public
il ya les syndicats qui peuvent faire
grève lorsqu'il estime nécessaire et les
responsables politiques qui doivent
esquisser des propositions
externe et les enseignants
je comprends les enseignants je
comprends les parents d'élèves qui
aujourd'hui sont dans la confusion et je
ne comprends pas ce gouvernement qui
aurait pu anticiper alors que
l'opposition républicaine avait proposé
justement des solutions qui auraient
permis d'anticiper et de ne pas se
retrouver dans cette situation un mot
sur la politique de tests massif qui est
poursuivie par le gouvernement est ce qu
elle encore un sens
selon vous oui je crois moi je suis pour
une politique de test ou dit massive
mais lorsque j'observe ce qui se passe
chez nos voisins en grande bretagne il y
a dix millions d'autos test par jour 10
millions d'autos test par jour nous en
sommes à dix millions d'autos test par
semaine donc je ne suis pas certain
qu'on ait une politique de masse il
revend ce que j'observe c'est que là
aussi puisqu'il n'y a pas eu de
préparation réel il y a certes des tests
mais il ya aussi la confusion avec des
queues devant les pharmacies avec un
protocole qui change tous les jours donc
plus personne ne sait exactement ce
qu'il doit faire quand il doit le faire
et où aller pour le faire donc je
comprends la confusion aujourd'hui mais
je ne l'acceptent pas et lorsque l'on se
compare on observe en fait que la
politique de test du gouvernement actuel
n'est pas la bonne et qu'elle est sans
doute pas suffisante parce que dans
d'autres pays il ya beaucoup plus
d'autos tests qui sont réalisés le sénat
entame donc aujourd'hui en séance
l'examen du texte sur le passé vaccinale
est ce que la majorité sénatoriale de
droite sera moins 10 les éclés réputé
est ce que vous voulez appeler à voter
massivement en grande majorité ce texte
oui je crois je crois que ce pass
vaccinale nécessaire
j'observe quand même que deux tiers des
députés les républicains ne se sont pas
opposés à ce passe vaccinale
même si évidemment chacun doit respecter
ses convictions personnelles son éthique
personnelle et non seulement un tiers la
beauté oui mais c'est
pour un tir contre un tiers d'abstention
ce qui sera plus clair au sénat 2 tient
s'y sont pas opposés
je ne suis pas sénateur donc je n'ai pas
à dicter sa conduite à chaque sénateur
en revanche ce que j'observe c'est qu'il
y a eu des avancées qui ont été
effectuées grâce la commission des lois
du sénat présidée par philippe bas nous
verrons si ces avancées ce que vous
suivez et chiant mais le pass actional
s'applique uniquement quand il n'ya plus
de dix mille patients hospitalisés
internationale ça c'est bien pour vous
moi je trouve qu'à titre personnel c'est
une bonne chose et j'imagine que nous
aurons une majorité au sénat en faveur
de ce pass vaccinale avec les
ajustements qui ont été opérés et c'est
là où j'observe je le dis non pas parce
que je suis public sénat mais que le
sénat et le mali est le meilleur allié
des français parce que lorsqu'il ya une
confusion à l'assemblée nationale et
nous avons tous déploré ce qui s'est
passé avec une majorité présidentielle
certes pléthorique mais qui n'était pas
vraiment au rendez vous au moment où il
fallait quand même aller voter et bien
la sagesse du sénat sa capacité à
combiner la préservation de la santé de
chacun nos concitoyens mais aussi le
respect des libertés publiques doit
rester un défi permanent et bien je
crois que c'est le sénat qui est au
rendez vous il faudra d'ailleurs bien
veiller aussi aux travaux de la
commission mixte paritaire pour que les
avancées du sénat puisse être confirmé
et confortée ensuite dans le final
gouvernement ne suive pas les la volonté
des sénateurs j'ai beaucoup de doutes
sur la capacité du gouvernement
effectivement à écouter l'opposition
républicaine au jeu sur les propos
d'emmanuel mâcon sur le fait de vouloir
emmerder les non vaccinés est ce que ça
peut compliquer l'examen de ce texte et
l'acceptation de ce pass vaccinale par
les français je crois que ça complique
surtout son rapport à la france son
rapport aux français la capacité des
français à accepter qu'un président
sortant s'exprime ainsi on pense ce que
l'on veut des noms vacciner d'ailleurs
observé une chose c'est que le président
sortant a parlé des non vaccinés et pas
des anti vaccins c'est à dire qu'au
passage il s'est quand même permis le
luxe
entre guillemets d'humilier certains nos
concitoyens qui subissent des
comorbidités et qui ne peuvent pas se
faire vacciner parce que ce serait
dangereux pour eux un président de la
république un président de tous les
français s'expriment ainsi humilie
insultes certains français qui subissent
des comorbidités et puis globalement
quoi qu'on pense même des anti vax et je
sais que je ne pense pas du bien on ne
s'exprime pas ainsi à l'égard de
français qui n'enfreignent pas là lourd
je préfère concentrer mon attention
surtout c
kaïd ces délinquants qui ne viole la loi
tous les jours qui empoisonnent la vie
des français honnêtes et qui eux pour le
coup ne sont pas suffisamment puni ne
sont pas suffisamment sanctionné et là
dessus il ya une
de l'autorité judiciaire en tout cas de
la politique pénale on va parler de lui
avec vous et sympathisants quelques
instants mais est-ce que les propos
d'emmanuel ma quoi ils peuvent expliquer
selon vous le regain de mobilisation des
anti vagues ce qu'on a vu ce week-end
dans les rues mais lorsqu'on division
fracture lorsqu'on dresse cyniquement
les français les uns contre les autres
évidemment il ne faut pas s'étonner
qu'il y ait des réactions que je ne peux
que déplorer et condamner mais qui
malheureusement s'explique même si
encore une fois ils sont condamnables
juste avant de passer à la sécurité jean
castex réunit aujourd'hui les différents
partis politiques pour pour installer un
petit comité de suivi pour les sourds
autour des conditions d'organisation de
la campagne présidentielle succo vide
est-ce que ça c'est une bonne méthode
est ce que c'est intéressant et qu'est
ce que les républicains vont demander au
premier ministre en la matière
quand on n'étouffe pas le débat
présidentiel il ya en 2017 la droite
pardon s'est fait voler l'élection
présidentielle ça ne doit pas être 40
2022 si nous nous savons qu
effectivement ce n'est pas une campagne
commune autre que tout est différent
qu'il faut davantage miser sur les
réseaux sociaux est peut-être un peu
moins sur les rassemblements et sur les
meetings mais le débat doit avoir lieu
parce que les français méritent ce débat
pas seulement sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire sous lequel il ya beaucoup à
dire mais aussi face aux problèmes
économiques et aux primes de pouvoir
d'achat face à l'insécurité culturel que
subissent un grand nombre de nos
concitoyens face à la faillite de la sur
la sécurité parce que le bilan
sécuritaire des manuels macro et
malheureusement catastrophique on va
sans doute en parler dans quelques
instants donc ce que nous souhaitons
c'est que le débat puisse avoir lieu il
ne soit pas mis sous l'étouffoir par une
stratégie cynique de la part du
président sortant et de son équipe qui
consiste à tenter de faire taire le
débat présidentiel
qui s'ils répondent ils à tous les
partis une cliente jamais atteint on
peut faire toutes les consultations
possible moi je vous parle sur le fond
ce débat doit avoir lieu peu importe les
modalités il y à des textes législatifs
qui
sont très au clair sur l'organisation
d'une campagne présidentielle appliquons
l'est et ne faisons pas de cette
campagne une non campagne voici le
message des républiques et vous pensez
vraiment que la majorité va essayer de
la majorité présidentielle va essayer
d'étouffer le débat dont d'empêcher le
débat dans le cadre la présidentielle ah
oui je pense vraiment et sous quelle
forme comment commence comme il le fait
tous les jours quand le président
sortant insultes certains des français
vous croyez que c'est pour cultiver un
débat sain apaiser un débat de fond est
ce que vous ne croyez pas que c'est une
stratégie cynique pour qu'on ne parle
que de ça pendant une semaine et qu'on
oublie les sujets essentiels écoutez on
connaît ses méthodes on sait très bien
qu'il n'a qu'un intérêt c'est d'avoir
l'extrême droite en face de lui car
l'extrême droite et son assurance
victoires et vient j'estime que ce n'est
pas sain pour la démocratie
le propre d'une démocratie c'est de
pouvoir avoir une alternance
républicaine
eh bien ce n'est pas du tout la
stratégie du président sortant et vous
le savez
ma couette et yanis
macron veut doubler les forces de police
sur le terrain d'ici 2030 augmenter le
budget de 25 % en cinq ans a fait 15
milliards est ce que ce sont des mesures
que vous saluer et s'il valérie pécresse
était président de la république à ce
qu'elle poursuivra cette loi de
programmation
j'ai trouvé le meeting électoral parce
qu'en fait c'est un meeting électoral et
non pas une sortie d'un président parce
que tout ce qu'il annonce de toute façon
ne pourrait être mise en place qu'après
son quinquennat j'ai trouvé ce meeting
électoral assez indécent parce que le
bilan sécuritaire
emmanuel macron est catastrophique ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est le
ministère de l'intérieur les données du
ministère de l'intérieur sont alarmantes
+ 32 % de coups et blessures volontaires
durant ce quinquennat +32 % ça veut dire
qu'il ya 800 français et françaises qui
sont agressés chaque jour sur notre
territoire + 12 % d' homicide est ce que
vous savez mal à mancini qu'il ya eu
plus de cambriolages en 2020 alors que
les français restait souvent chez eux du
fait du confinement
et donc par définition empêcher
peut-être davantage les cambriolages il
ya eu plus de cambriolages en 2020 qui
n'y en avait sous le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy donc la situation est
plus que préoccupante et emmanuel macron
vient s'adresser des satisfecit et nous
annoncer qu'il va doubler les forces de
police pour 2000 kw à 2030 mais moi ce
que j'aurais aimé c'est surtout qu'il
préserve la sécurité des français en
2017 2018 2019 et 2020
budget durant son quinquennat oui plus
effectif moins de policiers de gendarmes
sur le terrain là non plus ce n'est pas
moi qui le dit le taux d'engagement des
forces de l'ordre a baissé sous le kaka
ni manioc ah mais attendez la réduction
à par respect pour ceux qui nous
regardent sur du nombre de forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain l adl a démarré
le 6 ou le sous le sous le quinquennat
de nicolas sarkozy et alors il y avait
moins de délinquance la différence c'est
que ce quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy la
délinquance baissait encore une fois ce
n'est pas moi c'est le ministère de
l'intérieur qui dévoile ces chiffres et
qui sont d'autres objectifs la
délinquance avait baissé de 17% sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy et s'il y
avait moins d'effectifs on faisait
manifestement mieux et il y avait plus
de policiers et de gendarmes sur le
terrain c'est important ça que vous le
sachiez plus de policiers de gendarmes
sur le terrain sous le quinquennat
nicolas sarkozy qui en a maintenant
puisque le 'dow' d'engagement des forces
de l'ordre sur le terrain qui mesure la
présence réelle sur le terrain par
rapport au nombre de forces de l'ordre
et bien a baissé de deux points chez les
policiers de neuf points chez les gens
d'arrêt du quinquennat c'est leur choix
de programmation qu'elles ont été
annoncés hier qui sera présente en
masque est un peu la conclusion du monde
de la sécurité qui prévoient
l'augmentation du budget de 15 millions
d'ici 2027 est ce que si valérie
pécresse est élue elle reprendra cette
fois de programmation d'abord cette loi
de programmation elle n'est pas crédible
au regard du manque de résultats que
malheureusement nous subissons valérie
pécresse a fait des propositions bien
avant celle d'emmanuel macron et elle a
une différence avec emmanuel macron sait
que l dès qu'une mission lui est confiée
dès qu'un mandat lui confier elle fait
elle tient elle obtient des résultats
donc si elle est élue cette loi elle ira
aux oubliettes mais c'est pas sa loi qui
rasent oubliettes nous nous avons des
propositions
effectivement et nous disons certes il
faut des policiers des gendarmes sur le
terrain c'est une évidence mais il faut
une sanction à la fin parce que il ya
tellement de forces de l'ordre qui nous
disent nous interpellons nous
identifions le caïd le délinquant et le
problème c'est que à la fin ils se
retrouvent dans la rue où ils se
retrouvent avec une sanction qui
consiste à porter un bracelet
électronique qui la légion d'honneur des
caïds dans leur quartier donc nous ce
que nous voulons c'est des peines
certaines des peines effectivement
exécutées avec par exemple par exemple
une peine minimale d'un an en prison et
pas dans la rue et en goguette en prison
pour tous ceux qui se sont pris aux
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
c'est à dire les élus la république les
maires évidemment les forces de l'ordre
elle m'a parlé de la présidentielle de
la question des parrainages dans
quelques instants mais d'abord
évidemment on a envie de vous entendre
sur le ralliement guillaume pelletier
eric zemmour vous le connaissez bien
guillaume pelletier vous avez fondé à la
droite forte avec lui quelle a été votre
réaction en apprenant son aliment eric
et moi je n'ai pas été surpris
malheureusement guillaume c'est est
isolé depuis plusieurs mois il avait
déjà critiqué sa famille politique pour
ma part je ne les jamais quitté on peut
avoir des désaccords mais je crois qu'il
ne faut jamais quitté le navire et ce
n'était pas une surprise je peux je le
regrette et surtout guillaume pelletier
mais malheureusement
j'étais une candidate qui a elle même
acquis tels navires à un moment
ok mais elle a joué le jeu jusqu'au bout
et à chaque fois même quand elle avait
des désaccords elle a dit je respecterai
les règles de ma famille politique et
c'est exactement ce qu'elle a fait et
c'est d'ailleurs aussi l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles la susciter la confiance
des adhérents les républicains ce n'est
pas tout à fait la même démarche que
guillaume qui lui a malheureusement fait
le jointe le fait le choix de rejoindre
l'extrême droite et en agissant ainsi il
fait le jeu des manuels macron il
devient le complice et emmanuel macron
parce que comme je le disais il ya
quelques instants c'est exactement la
stratégie cynique du président sortant
c'est de faire monter l'extrême droite
pour être sûr de gagner à la fin et bien
malheureusement guillaume est tombé dans
le piège et il participe à ce jeu si
nîmes et lui dit la même chose par le
président c'est moi je ne soutiens pas
valérie pécresse parce qu'elle fait le
jeu des manuels macron gabon c'est de
vous croyez que si elle faisait le jeu
des manuels macron emmanuel macron ne
nous aurait pas envoyé cinq ministres
lors des élections régionales vous
trouvez vraiment qu emmanuel macron
porte la même politique que celle que
valérie pécresse propose qui consiste à
être beaucoup plus dur est beaucoup plus
fort à l'égard des délinquants alors que
je viens de vous énoncer un bilan
sécuritaire catastrophique du président
sortant non je crois que ça na rien a
été le seul candidat de la droite c'est
un examen comment vous l'entendez ça
mais la droite c'est quoi la droite
c'est l'amicale du maréchal pétain la
droite c'est celle qui consiste que les
femmes et je m'adresse à vous non pas le
droit d'exercer le pouvoir la droite
c'est celle qui trouve des excuses à
tariq ramadan c'est ça la droite
républicaine c'est ça l'adn du général
de gaulle c'est ça que nous a appris
nicolas sarkozy pour lesquels guillaume
et moi avons oeuvré non ça c'est pas la
droite c'est la dérive sectaire de la
droite et qui devenu l'extrême droite la
droite républicaine s'est nouée sur le
fond nous n'avons absolument pas besoin
d'être extrémiste pour être offensif et
c'est exactement ce qu'a toujours
démontré valérie pécresse notamment
comme présidente de la région ile de
france où elle a par exemple créé la
charte de la laïcité c'est à dire plus
un euro d'argent public pour les
associations qui dépassent les bornes de
la république comme par hasard l'extrême
droite a refusé de voter cette mesure
parce que dit que nous mettons en oeuvre
une mesure offensive eh bien ça
n'arrange pas l'extrême droite pour une
raison simple c'est que l'extrême droite
vis de ces problèmes les problèmes des
français c'est son fond de commerce il
est tout seul guillaume pelletier il
s'en va parce qu'il a plus sa place aux
républicains il n'a pas d'avenir dans ce
parti s'est complètement individuel ou
d'autres cadres d'autres grands élus de
votre parti vont le suivre t je n'ai pas
vu la vague déferle et il y aura
peut-être ici ou là quelques
individualités qui pour un plat de
lentilles se feront acheté par un autre
candidat je ne le sais pas je ne le
souhaite pas en tout cas déjà des échos
vous savez déjà que non non non je ne me
permettrais pas de penser ainsi de faire
de procès d'intention à personne mais je
crois que l'immense majorité
la quasi intégralité
guillaume pelletier excepté des élus les
républicains ont compris que valérie
pécresse serai une présidente de droite
comme elle l'a toujours été c'est à dire
une femme libre une femme de conviction
une femme offensive et une femme pardon
de le souligner et d'insister qui
obtient des résultats parce qu'il s'agit
de ça on n'est pas là juste pour faire
une analyse du paysage politique à
l'instant t on est là pour se tourner
vers les français et régler leurs
problèmes parce que malheureusement ils
n'ont pas été mais quand même un
affaiblissement dans la campagne de
valérie pécresse serait venu en
pâtissait pas révélateur de quelque
chose je ne crois pas je crois que c'est
précisément l'inversé que c'est un acte
isolé où il est reparti vers là d'où il
venait je le regrette parce que j'appris
si guillaume à titre personnel et que je
n'enlève rien des souvenirs que nous
avons porté ensemble en créant la droite
forte mais je me souviens que l'adn de
la droite forte l'adn de nicolas sarkozy
s'était précisément de se battre contre
l'extrême droite celui qui faisait
baisser l'extrême droite c'était nicolas
sarkozy donc entre eux ce qui rejoint
une extrême droite et ceux qui trouvent
des solutions pour faire baisser
l'extrême droite je préfère la seconde
option
un certain nombre de deux dina deux
grands candidats qui potentiellement
sont qualifiés pour le second tour
s'inquiète du fait de ne pas avoir le
nombre de parrainages suffisants qu'est
ce que vous en pensez qu est ce qu on
peut faire il ya notamment david lisnard
qui dit qu'il est ouvert à une réforme
d'urgence s'il ya unanimité au parlement
sur la question qu'on pensait que ce
serait une bonne solution une réforme
d'urgence qui consisterait à rétablir
l'anonymat des élus qui parraine c'est
bien ça en
tout cas c'est un des points clés en
fait le fait qu'ils aient pas d'anonymat
fait qu'il ya beaucoup d'élus qui
n'osent pas accorder leur parrainage de
peur d'être sanctionner entre guillemets
de toute manière cette mesure si elle
devait être mise en place ne
s'appliquerait pas évidemment vous le
savez pour cette échéance présidentielle
si elle s'appliquerait pour d'autres là
nous parlons l'élection présidentielle
de 2000 22 mois je suis voltairien dans
l'âme c'est à dire que je me bats pour
que même ceux avec lesquels je ne suis
pas d'accord puisse s'exprimer donc la
magie magie jean luc mélenchon qu'on
soit clair jean luc mélenchon est un
eczéma marine le pen on doive être sur
la ligne de départ en tout cas ce n'est
pas à moi de le dire c'est aussi lui qui
parraine en tout cas on vous le fera
normal qu'ils nous sommes là quand drian
il exprime des courants de pensée et
quand on exprime un courant de pensée
représenté dans l'opinion j'estime 5e
ces courants de pensée puissent être
représentées et faire l'objet
d'éventuels suffrages ça c'est mon
opinion personnelle après évidemment
amer les républicains à vocation
naturellement spontanément par cohérence
à parrainer le en l'espèce la candidate
issue de sa famille politique c'est à
dire valérie pécresse donc moi je ne
condamne personne je ne juge personne je
dit juste c'est ce que je condamne
auriez les maires l'est républicain qui
apportent leur parrainage de soutien qui
n'est pas un soutien justement mais qui
est pourtant
juste un parrainage pourtant d'avoir
jean luc mélenchon à un moment d'être
candidat dans dans votre question il ya
déjà un élément de réponse vous dites
parrainé et ou soutenir on peut pas
rêver sans soutenir bon mais avec les
maires l air qui parraine ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'il y ait de la
cohérence et que les maires les
républicains c'est mon souhait personnel
se tourner vers la candidate issue des
républicains mais vous savez bien que
personne ne dit pas qui que ce soit sa
conduite et que les maires sont
souverains c'est leur choix personnel
moi je souhaite qu'il puisse soutenir
valérie pécresse mais en même temps
chacun est libre est ce que je souhaite
plus globalement pour l'ensemble de la
démocratie c'est que tous ceux qui
expriment un courant de pensée puisse
être représentée au suffrage qu'est ce
que je souhaite enfin c'est la victoire
de valérie pécresse par exemple la seule
candidate qui va régler les problèmes
mais surtout pour une raison simple
c'est que l'extrême droite ne peut pas
gagner l'extrême droite va permettre une
réélection d'emmanuel macron et sage
estime que ses seins et dangereux pardon
merci beaucoup si geoffrey dit d'arrêter
anna travail était ce matin
[Musique]